You guys love reliving the invention of
the Greek and Roman alphabets like it's
some climax in the history of writing,
but real language nerds drool over Korean.
And here's why.
Another time, another king,
this time in a Korean palace,
he presents himself as king. Say, Joan,
as you get a grip on your surroundings,
you began to tell him of your journeys.
Yet with a sweeping gaze,
the king books right past you,
you've been out for a very long time.
Over a thousand years,
the world has come so far,
and the scripts you once knew have to,
he reminds you of the old Chinese local
graphs and sound meaning combinations.
Those are still useful to his
court to appoint. You See,
Chinese has these nice word units,
one after another,
but Korean he boasts has these elegantly
complex words with different pieces and
endings. Fitting Chinese writing
to Korean grammar hasn't been easy.
He tells you other people across the sea
who've gone through a similar struggle.
The Japanese simplified Chinese
characters by turning them into a fixed
syllabary, which they now use
alongside the Chinese characters.
So they have these syllable characters
and these thousands of Han characters,
they use the Han characters for
the meaning heavy components.
They'll tabulary terms.
Then they use the syllabary
to write little grammatical
words and word pieces or
new vocabulary words that
don't historically have
their own Chinese logo graph.
Such a complicated system,
gentlemen,
the king has an almost puzzle book
like he's holding back a punchline.
He recounts how an Old Japan women wrote
entire books using only the syllable
characters because writing with the
traditional Han characters was seen as the
masculine thing to do,
but he knows of another land.
He's heard exotic tales of the West where
people write out all of their sounds.
Logically, he pauses, he can't
quite grasp this himself.
You snicker as you think back on how you
saw the alphabet develop with your own
eyes and your journeys,
you would know.
So you sit down and show him how to
write every vowel and consonant with the
alphabet, a couple of dozen shapes
and you can write any sound.
You smile and think so simple, but
he lets out an unimpressed. Sy,
why do all the characters look so
different? So haphazard? I mean,
you make fun and VA by putting your
bottom lip against your top teeth.
The only difference is that your throat
vibrates. When you say VA, he quizzes you.
Why do you write fuck and VA?
And he goes on interrogating you.
What about why does it look that way
when it's just taking the VUS sound and
seeing it through smacked lips
seems you underestimated the king.
He doesn't want any old alphabet.
He wants a writing system that shows
the various features of sounds that the
sound is made in your throat against your
teeth, made with your lips and so on.
He puts his brightest scholars to work,
giving them the humble name of the
hall of worthies in go the experts and
outcomes and other major moments
in the history of writing.
They develop Korean Hungle,
a featural alphabet.
Every syllable gets separated out into
its own block. The syllables, consonants,
and vowels will be written
side by side within that block.
Each consonant and vowel letter inside
that block will be shaped according to
its features. So here are the consonants
that get pronounced with the lips.
See the similar lip shape.
Here's God, and here's cut.
Again,
similar sounds similar shape.
The featural alphabet was so
simple and straight forward.
One of the king's historians almost dared
people to learn it. If you're smart,
you can learn it in one morning. If
you're a fool, it'll take you 10 days.
Not everyone's jumping on the Hungle.
Easy train community accessible writing
bothers traditionalist who skip out on
the innovation and keep
using Chinese characters,
fit it to Korean Honjo or hand characters,
even into the 19 hundreds still for
the rest. Writing is easier than ever.
It has its first rock star. It even
gets its own holiday. Oh, writing.
You've come a long,
long way from pictographs in a cave.